okay people joining this live stream we
are looking at functions that were
tagged as experimental in previous
versions of Wolfram language and the
question is can we make them not
experimental going forward okay we're
looking at machine learning methods and
my men are the first one so these are
the first for all method for learn
distribution and I think this one we
should actually change the name because
contingency table seems obscure to many
people and now we're going to have
categorical distribution in 12.1 as a as
a top-level distribution so I think we
should call it category category core
method are no categorical because it
will return a categorical distribution
it's not what you're saying no it
returns a normal distribution so it's a
method of learn distribution so it
always returns around distribution
mm-hmm but the method underneath is
really the categorical distribution is
the same thing except that at a time we
didn't name the top level so for example
for multi normal I call it meat almost
no more because we have negative normal
distribution in the system and I didn't
call it Gaussian or you know
well except the Gaussian is called
normal distribution exactly in the
system that's why the method is also
called actually yeah call it multinomial
we could change okay actually that's
another thing that I've been bugging me
yes
I call it multi normal and I had second
thought of just calling it no more even
though it's it works both for univariate
and multi-dimensional that's another
thing we could change look if this is
about the distribution we better call it
normal distribution because having a
method arrow normal is pretty weird
oh so you mean to keep it middle to
normal no I'm gonna call it normal
distribution automatic distribution on
the categorical through the distribution
but I don't know if that's correct
learn distribution with method arrow
categorical distribution is that
sensible it does that not make sense in
the context of learn distribution I
think the distribution is a bit
redundant but well kernel density
estimation what is the distribution
associated with that it's a mixture of Y
a mixture of normal distribution so and
how does that differ from Gaussian
mixture Gaussian mixture in kernel
density estimation you're the same
number of distribution as a number of
data point when Gaussian mixture it's
finds you know that clusters
do we really want no shade of blue in
these to indicate that they're links
maybe I mean a good usual agreement
doesn't matter but um I don't know what
to make of these names and where's norm
that work
it's not even listed here neural network
is not so no this new network was the
last method of classify predict that is
experimental and all I said yeah which I
think it should stay experimental
because we are we change our mind so
much with these methods so although now
we have more like prudent you know more
careful strategy and others small number
of hyper parameters like we a diaper
parameters only when we show that we are
going to keep it like Network depth you
know since my parameter will be here to
stay but but many times the only talks
can mean so many thing that and I per
parameter don't make any sense it's
important well maybe we shouldn't just
have a single neural network matter what
about that's yeah we thought about that
but we could also have like you know
architecture convolutional architecture
recurrent yeah we've been debating
internally about that many you know talk
method or just one and so which is why I
think it should say experimental like
the on talk world will not exactly sure
how it's going to evolve okay let's look
down this list here okay so these things
are basically using a certain kind of
distribution for the learn distribution
correct yes okay so what is the name of
that type of distribution like for
example what how would we make a
Gaussian mixture in our standard
distribution framework actually think
it's going mixture that's the world
isn't that mixture distribution I think
there's something specific for that
right
oh no it's maybe a method of of
clustering no it would be with mixture
distribution yes but it's all
method in like fine clusters
I assume okay so I mean the question is
are these named and branded method oh
yes yes they are they are they are
they're Gaussian mixture is a big brand
careless emission is a big brand so I've
no doubt about this to name decision
tree is a big brand contention see table
they would use it more in statistics we
talk about contingency table so this is
not a big big name and multi normal you
know because as Gosha and so on it
actually doesn't know more versus multi
normal so both of them wears normal it's
you you there's a new method that you
might add which is just a normal
distribution or you saying multi normal
I'm saying well multi normal also works
when it's not many viable if you just
give a bunch of numbers and you say
method multi no more it's gonna work so
it's actually not a multi normal at the
time you're not using learned
distribution to learn most of time
though that's why I just call it Molino
mall and and also I think I had the same
feeling as you like just method goes to
no more was a bit weird or I would I
mean if the language already add didn't
already have a multi normal symbol which
actually actually might be able to work
with only one viable just know for sure
of lenss one it does so if they didn't
have this totally normal a multi normal
distribution in my view
well they're all distribution so we just
call ya Lutie normal is good what's
wrong more is good yeah
okay categorical though seems odd and
given that most of these are essentially
brand names were methods I would have
thought that can you know I don't
understand why you want to go away from
if contingency table is any kind of
reasonable brand why you want to go away
from that just because we're going to
have a symbol that is called categorical
distribution and that is a but how close
is what this is doing to a categorical
does the same same thing it is just a
critical distribution code in its table
like it's like write discretize every
viable and you have a big
multi-dimensional array and just store a
number I know it's right yeah as a
method that's more a contingency table
categorical is what you distribution is
what comes out of it true could give
this yeah same as was killed in
situation I guess I think you should
leave contingency table it sounds much
more like a a method
and I think you should go ahead and do
experimental eyes all of these I don't
see any reason yeah yep yep except me
all Network I think
I sure hope this page as a seal so to
all of the what if these dot dots here I
think it's a burg I just saw that before
and by the way this fee also should
surely point to net tray head train yes
it should M I'm surprised actually I
wonder if it's not supposed to be
between these dots but maybe we forgot
that also I have to say that in that I
think stuff like this should be ionized
and documentation in good I mean that's
a general thing rush you should bring
that up with them with Brian I guess is
to go through and icon eyes you know
complicated plotting options like that
when they're purely subsidiary ok I will
mention it to him okay all right um I'm
a little worried about a thing um yeah I
mean we are starting to use me on that
as part of the default choice of methods
right
no not right now no right now it is too
experimental
it's also quite of a different time
scale it's quite slower than the other
ones but it might performance call
quality and I'm pretty sure we don't at
the moment like we're waiting one round
maybe every way yeah the idea was to add
it pretty soon
and actually it's working great so so we
should add it when this performance
quality or very high time goal
yeah I know we should we should add it
we'll just to be careful because in the
past is the own network method you don't
work that well
nice looking pretty well since we change
to self normalizing your networks mm-hmm
no of course but works well so we should
probably add it to the fine thing
what are the detailing sub-option okay I
guess I can check that Montag you should
click detail in solution you will see
the nodes the tail-end sub-option
isn't that that [ __ ] that's a bug by the
way Raj that should show a um a
thumbnail there right yep yep I got it
what the heck is this step for the net
okay lovely is as free as the
sub-options so all a third of options
can be given well he's the options of
the method I don't know actually it's a
sub options yeah internally we often
further interruptions and also I think
it should have a pattern for how those
sub options are inserted what do you
mean where it should say the following
so options can be given in the form oh
yes yes yes neuron that blah blah blah
opt arrow whatever it is or something
yeah yeah yeah that's true also I don't
understand why this type is smaller head
and it is up here I got a bug yep like
it the next we there's not even a gray
so it's must be a difference yeah
something goofed up that following that
table probably I see other issues with
with that page so I'll file all of them
okay okay um what were you just grazing
oh yeah how the performance goal stuff
works
you
you
well I think quality is a clear one huh
I mean another one which which is
classifier size which I don't think o
memory
yeah it's memory yeah yeah we don't we
don't control the training memory
because this we assume it should you
know be automatic by checking on memory
doesn't own computer
mohamad on livestream is pointing out
the contingent table has a name in the
actuarial world is that the name I think
that's the name isn't it in other words
is that is it conflictive with what
we're doing or is it aligned with what
we're doing
I believe it's aligned um okay let's go
on to the next item text analysis do we
need um yeah this this gonna be simple
there's really two things right there's
text cases and or it's friend
and then there's text structure okay so
the main thing about text cases is I
want to consider making interpretation
bid with the default that's one thing
but maybe that's wrong I don't know if
that's right um it's good for demos I'm
not sure it's good for usage because
obviously it's confusing when things
aren't interpreted because the NLU and
I'll play loop that doesn't close yes
there is that is that me things are
going to be yea removed because there's
no interpretation in some cases there's
big problems like for person because our
diffusion of person is whoever isn't a
person and interpreter is like notable
people right there's things like that
just leaves the thing as a string if it
can't interpret it doesn't remove it
when just a text case is yeah it will
remove it no it doesn't
I've done it many times it doesn't
remove it currently it doesn't remote
okay okay no your there's two things
there's option very fine interpretation
I thought you meant this very fine
interpretation will remove them when
they have no interpretation if you set
it to true yes
oh no then the output I think should be
a stream because it's the case is you
give a text which is a string and you
ask piece of this text and I also like
sometimes it's not just one thing right
it's like text cases of English text
cases of you know and all the thing I've
written in English I think it should be
string yeah
fine okay let's look again at
okay verify interpretation
yeah that what do you mean it doesn't
used anywhere what do you mean isn't
used anywhere I mean it's it's the thing
what oh you say four verify
interpretation it's not used anywhere
else
don't XK geez
it's a option that is purely for text
gauges so I don't know I bet it's gonna
be needed for other things like image
cases and so on as well because think
about this I mean you know it is you
could end up with a rhinoceros
in context but if you try to verify it
as an independent rhinoceros it might
fail
so to speak I'm not sure what you want
to have happen in that case you see what
I'm saying that is in the context okay
it's a it's a boat you can tell it's a
boat because it's got ocean around it
right you then remove the boat and get
just its bounding box and you say is it
still a boat well we don't know perhaps
to be different because in that case
it's two models right in this in this
selecting a database like do we have
it's well late but I can imagine this
happening in other places yeah
I admit that I mean you know we our
development of NLU is more extensive
than our development of NIU so to speak
for images
um also I think as long as this case is
experimental I don't see and that it's
not used anywhere else I don't see why
we should the experimental eyes that one
no no no absolutely not
why does Texas cases have to stay
experimental because I mean I mean yeah
I think it's not really about a design I
think the design we we kind of get it
got it it's more about the the quality
of the model really not bad it's not for
the common things but truly you know we
advertised as 300 things we can
recognize well it's just recreated that
I said with 300 but most of them we can
recognize anything really I think so
and we haven't added because we didn't
have a real test set on my end yet which
we are trying to do we don't know yet
its weaknesses intense a lot I mean
honestly the model we use was kind of a
first prototype
of training a large you know was a large
training set with many many types and
done with a bunch of heuristics you know
how we did training set
I feel it's a definition of experiment
or for me like we have been
experimenting with this and it giving
something useful already so we put it
here but it's going to be it can be much
better and and we're going to do it much
better all right okay text element is
part of a family of complicated thing I
mean we really need to look at this it's
also related to xml elements and these
other things
Texas dime I'm sorry to say we probably
do need to keep these experimental what
about snippet
so I don't think it's my field
well interestingly
you
yeah I mean there was there's a case for
doing something like snippet Tom welcome
Jones needed this in some stuff to do
with the new data structure
functionality and I had forgotten about
snippet but it doesn't work on
expressions we might raise that with Tom
I mean I think this is a separate let's
let's raise that in an ILD meeting
please on earth yep I'm dumb snippet on
expressions and the relationship to what
we needed for data structure
um yes a bunch of cymbal
Stefano to complete snippet is complete
is a horror I don't know who that is
it's a complete horror it's completely
crazy in my view and I don't know what
happened to that project I don't know
where the Tsushima has that on the list
of on the global project list
um could Devin please is it seven
persons here yeah yeah I'm here after
four what is this regarding autocomplete
this is total mess and I don't know what
its status isn't does Sushma have that
on the list and and as where is this
thing I don't even know because it also
relates to you know a lot of what
autocomplete is about it's about having
the API and the cloud to be able to do
it
all right well that wasn't very
encouraging
either are usually less encouraged by
this one oh my gosh look at these open
your network stuff it's just one package
now I mean I kind of agree that um hello
yes really you were Yuma too
ethan on our live stream is complaining
that text structure still fails on a on
a famous grammatically correct sentence
i want to see what it does now
oops
I can't even imagine what it thinks is
going on here and I think it might even
make sense if you add two more Buffalo I
think I've seen it was seven my mad wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
is this not the correct porous
I don't know what the correct parse is
but that's not an obviously stupid
parses it okay nobody here composite as
a human
it's hope since what's that it's
extremely confusing I think I think
actually it makes sense right
I don't know what it means
yes I don't know enough about the
meaning okay so that is yeah exactly it
says it's an adjective that is odd I I
think the second-to-last buffalo should
be the proper noun but then maybe it
should have been capitalized I don't
know think about this if about this
exact phrase and how what each of those
should be okay okay but listen there's
another issue here which is this is
tagging the word Buffalo is an adjective
yet our part of speech system doesn't
think it can be an adjective so I'm
saying so that's something is wrong
there
you understand Raj ah sure I'll report
that right I mean it's a bug of some
kind somewhere I mean it may not be it
may be because we're using very
different technology for this case um
okay so did it get it right for this
case can somebody look from the do I
have to do do I have to type in
Wikipedia data of this eight of them in
Wikipedia right so that's the Wikipedia
five there's eight buffalos this Adi
fellow and the third is capital the
first third and second from last of
uppercase okay I don't know how many no
idea what this means
that's seven right so apparently the
city in my fellow other is yes and
there's I see I see I see I see yeah
okay which are the one should be
capitalized to us here
oh I see Buffalo buffalo
now I'm so confused
I don't know if that's correct it
doesn't look right to me but I don't
know okay
in any case if this is our worst problem
a text structure I would say text
structure is doing very very well okay
let's go back to neural nets so I kind
of agree that we're not ready to do
experimental eyes the whole thing um
I kind of still feel that there may be
some better formalism particularly with
all of the stuff to do with them
well a net function and be the
the ports the way ports work and I also
wonder how ports relate to hypergraphs
hypergraphs
yes in other words could we go
reformulate I mean ports I don't think
we formulated ports very well in graphs
in general have we I mean graphs don't
have ports in general settings when you
construct the graph though it's a little
hard to hear you but but but that's not
what I'm talking about what I'm talking
about is the core graph functionality
does not support ports for nodes that is
but it does now support tagging of edges
right edge can now have tagging so I'm
confused what the relationship between
tagged edges and ports is and that's
something we probably should ask Charles
now the only issue is that I think a
tagged edge is an edge that has a tag
where the tag is the same at the two
ends of the edge right whereas a port
we're saying this edge connects to this
port of this node see what I'm saying
that's in you understand what I'm saying
yes yep okay so I think we need to raise
that and Devin I think that's for you
with Charles and the graph theory people
because I think that to me seems like it
remains a weakness of the neuron that
framework in that what we effectively
have is a flow of data through these
neural nets that is so we have a graph
representing a flow of data but we have
these ports that are kind of hacky that
say how the data is flowing into
functions
it's like named arguments of functions
right that fair assess characterization
anyway I think I think there's more that
could be done on this and I have a
feeling that as we build out hyper
graphs and things we may want to do that
so I kind of agree we should leave this
experimental oh well
that's a lot of functions
okay um by the way on the livestream Ali
is suggesting a session where users can
say things they want and get updates on
how things are going that is a perfectly
good idea I mean what we have right now
we just recently started our sessions
going over reported bugs and so on but I
agree this is a perfectly reasonable
suggestion and perhaps Devin you could
take that suggestion and give it to
Danielle in our node and yeah I mean I'm
I'm perfectly up for that I think it's a
good idea we just had our annual
technology conference and some of that
happened well that happened in a much
more distributed fashion not just with
me at that conference and we got a lot
of a lot of - dues from that thanks to
people who were there um all right what
are you doing with this is this all a
bunch of X's as well same yeah why
because you're saying a poll fronting on
the all right fine yes
Metheny definitely and I clear some yeah
we're ready to do some change
when discussing possible multi-encoder
new input encoder which input decoder
that we kind of gave up because it was
actually design wise very complicated
like making things more complex rather
than more simple well you mean you mean
things where there's a understand where
you have heterogeneous data we have
audio and an image or something these
canes I think is fine actually right now
but sometimes you want to have one
encoder that has two input set for just
one input yeah I understand outputs
encoder no two input no an encoder input
yes and what's the Matteson issue of
ports or copying why isn't there I mean
given that we have this paradigm of
having functions that just you know
represent the different flow of data why
isn't there a sort of copying copy this
port to two outputs type function and I
thought we had that was basically just
from the design point of view we're
we're limiting once I remember about
that and you gave you yes you you gave
an ID to explore that I think in the end
couldn't work for some reason I kind of
I kind of forget but in case it was a
big mess and we kind of gave up even
though we had all the code ready and for
one version but all right okay yeah
sound like the highest priority and it
seems like
by the way s on our live stream is is
complaining that the neuron that
repository seems stale but I don't think
that's true I thought there wouldn't you
new things being put in all the time
there's only how do we how do we look at
it and see the M maybe it looks stale
because it's already got a lot of stuff
in it how do we look at the most recent
things that have been added from
repository I don't know there's their
browse by date there is a tag you see on
the bottom right there's a new tag on
South formalizing that from numeric data
so that I think is supposed to stay
there for like two weeks or something
actually okay so the rate at which
models few in it slow down a little bit
and the main reason is that we kind of
run out of interesting nets to import
with the automated importers and so the
reasons the most recent nuts had to be
imported in a you know without using any
automated tool so just by hand which
things yeah but so hopefully onyx will
be here soon and we will have a whole
bunch of networks that can then be
imported more easily exactly they're
also important networks we added like
you know birth gbgt gbg to like this was
like big stuff hard to import right so
the answer is it should speed up again
fairly soon as we get some onyx online
and also as I mentioned it was quite a
challenge to correctly represent the
Transformers models so birth gbg1 and
GPT - you know pushing our framework
like sometimes we have to update the
framework to make this network work
alright is some okay that that's that
for no-nuts then um okay so thank you
guys alright bye I don't think this is
going to go well this chat discussion do
we have the relevant people for the chat
discussion here Jay
I mean I don't think there's really
anything to discuss here you know with
the fact that the channel framework is
in flux and chat relies so heavily on it
there's I don't I don't I grow way as he
can every time I've tried to use chat
it's horrible things have happened now
that may be because the underlying
channel framework hasn't been strong
enough and hopefully that will be fixed
very soon here I mean you saw the
competition that you saw that you were
there for that was using some chat
behind the scenes and it worked so I
think pretty well so that was using the
new MQTT so exactly exactly yes yeah
well that's because the other one was
just a joke but it was still using the
chat code it was just running it on a
new back end right but using the same
functions here it's using the same code
base it wasn't actually using these it
was using some of these functions yeah I
guess the chat rooms were created using
these functions so I mean yeah the the
functionality was the Wolfram language
top-level functionality was the same
modulo a few tweaks that Jesse had to
make to make it work on mqtt but okay
but look once we have a solid back-end
there then let's look at then we can
relook at the chat exact line and that's
mean I think with the first step here
it's going to be things like streaming
notebooks and so on for which we
actually have a review this afternoon um
and then we'll get to this other stuff
after that yeah I agree
III just yeah I just don't think there's
any point in talking about this until
the backend selled fine all right I
think that concludes our meeting um
thanks everybody thanks to folks on the
livestream and see y'all soon